non-minimalists
you know the biggest thing i'm getting
from this this conversation
is a how important it is to live in the
moment like no matter where you're at in
life to
to find some way to appreciate
what you have and then the other thing
is josh and i talk a lot about
lowering expectations but raising our
standards and
uh when it comes to love when you know
that quote that uh
josh brought up about you know giving
something that you don't have to someone
that doesn't want it
it's like you well
the best way that i can explain it is
like living in los angeles
my experience with it it was really
rough at first yeah
and i was telling josh about this i'm
like dude i love l.a but l.a doesn't
really love me
and he's like what's wrong i'm like dude
i go to like coffee shop hey how's it
going
and they're just like yeah can i take
your order dude like what
what drugs are you on why are you so
happy what do you want out of me who do
you think you i mean there's like all
these
prejudgments so josh he's like dude you
have to you have to turn it down
or you need to turn it up yeah so i said
all right i'll turn it up
so now uh when i have those moments
where i walk in somewhere
and now like i have a regular spots
where like people you know they pretty
much know me by now
but you know i go somewhere hey hey i'm
ryan nice to meet you
how's your day going and they kind of
give me that what do you want to do what
drugs you're on i'll be like
can i take your order you can't take my
order but first i want you to tell me
how your day is going like i'll just you
know i'll just be kind of silly and
goofy
and i i will express that that you know
the kindness or the love that i feel
without any expectation of getting it
back yeah and sometimes i don't get it
back and that's okay but i will say that
when i
a like i'm in the moment with that love
and i push through that barrier
um i will have much better results and
results that i didn't expect so
you know when josh and i were having
that conversation and he was like yeah i
would recommend turning it down or
turning it up
um you know when i first started turning
it up i just thought i'm just gonna make
an ass of myself now like when i go to
different places
um but here you're very good at that but
yeah i really i'm very very good at that
um but it's but it turns out i'm about
20 good at that because
the majority of the event or 10 i mean
the majority of the time the vast
majority of the time
when i push through that barrier without
so so i'm living in the moment i i am
giving without any
with any expectation of giving back um
that is that's raising my standard
that's what i mean that's what we mean
by raising our standard my standard
is be myself be genuine push through be
honest
um and be consistent those are my
standards i don't expect josh to treat
me anyway if i act that way i don't
expect you to treat me a certain way if
i act that way
but what happens is by by forcing
i'm not forcing that but by i guess
pushing through that that um
the trepidation of of being ourselves
that truly to me is what uh is what is
freeing i guess is when you can
you can again love without expecting to
get loved back
um and and you can uh just yeah raise
those standards and and keep the low
expectations because
you know when you get when your
expectations are so low it's it's
you're really surprised with the results
you get a lot of times i think it's as
long as those standards are high too
of course the you know so we have
pete's book here which you can't get
unless you're a patreon supporter of his
it's called enduring love because i
think there's only 500 copies of the
thing
but but like it would be great love by
the way because love is so difficult to
endure
and because that's the thing we haven't
got into is that love is um lovers are
very difficult
it brings us to the heights but also the
depths anyway well and there's the thing
that
that i think about with with a book like
this with respect to
expectations versus standards like it'd
be really great if all of a sudden this
was it
sold a million copies a new york times
bestseller like that
but if that's your expectation going
into it even if you get that like that's
going to feel
fulfilling in for a moment but it's
going to be fleeting the standard
is like hmm but can i can i write a book
by the way this has a bunch of you know
it's a i guess you would call it
like comics or illustrations but with
like all of these little pithy
um uh aphorisms
parables etc um about enduring love
and the the the standard is like i'm
gonna put my best foot forward knowing
that
it's not going to be perfect it's never
going to be perfect it's not going to be
the superhero version
but i'm going when you talk about living
in the moment i'm going to enjoy doing
the actual work
of creating this thing yeah there's an
interesting distinction
uh in uh philosophy and psychoanalysis
between pleasure
and enjoyment and so of course we use
these words interchangeably in everyday
life
but you can distinguish them by saying
pleasure
is the uh good feeling you get from say
you know finishing the book and
enjoyment is the pleasure you get
uh the the warm feelings you get from
the work itself
so for at christmas time you see a kid
waiting for their christmas presents and
they almost hate it and they're jumping
up and not having a temper tantrum and
all of that but there's an enjoyment
they can't wait to get the present
that's enjoyment
and then pleasure is the moment that you
open the present and we all know that
that the enjoyment is better than the
pleasure right right that's what you
when you buy a holiday you're not just
buying a holiday
you're paying for the fantasy
of the holiday that's that's kind of
fooled it into the money
that's why you should never buy a
holiday off the cuff
or a lottery ticket your one dollar
isn't for the win you're paying a dollar
for the fantasy of the win
right so um and so we often think
that pleasure is the key the
the end but actually we have to find how
do we
get um a warmth and a depth from
enjoyment
which is the struggle and that's where
that's where love is because i think we
those ephemeral things we mistake for
love but really love is that deep
pursuit yeah i think about remember ella
on her
my daughter's five now but when she was
when she was three uh for her birthday i
got her a pineapple
for her third birthday and it perfectly
illustrates exactly what you're talking
about there there was
pleasure in the the opening of it but
the the enjoyment
was the anticipation she saw it wrapped
you could tell it was a freaking
pineapple
it was a it was a pineapple-shaped
present but like the
the the the the opening there was this
sort of fleeting ephemeral thing but
everything leading up to it yeah that
that enjoyment the anticipation
uh was uh was really what the
what was memorable of the experience